he's Nick nurse the head coach of my
Toronto Raptors no matter where he goes
he wins he's won in the d-league British
Basketball League the Belgian Basketball
League
all of the great leagues around the
world and he joins us now good morning
coach how are you if we don't have an
NBA season due then the Raptors carry
the title for another year are you
two-time NBA champ or one time really I
had a trivia question it's not a trivia
question I think it's just an
interesting fact schools to produce an
NBA Finals winning head coach and a
Super Bowl winning quarterback you're on
that list Nick Wow
Kurt Warner yes great Kurt Warner
Northern Iowa you're on that list with
Steve Kerr Arizona Nick Foles won a
Super Bowl awesome and here's one for
you Michigan is on the list Tom Brady
and Rudy Tomjanovich Wow so there there
you go you learned something that's it
that's all I needed to talk to you about
coach that is five really cool names to
be associated with that's awesome that's
awesome
how often you stay in touch with your
players not that often to be honest
we've had a few Xoom calls we've
certainly got somebody from our training
staff in touch with them almost every
day every other day assistant coaches
every every three or four days just just
to check in what did you make of
Shaquille O'Neal's saying they should
scrap the season all together well
that's a school of thought I guess I
mean it's been two months now I think
the time is on our side the longer we go
and get things out push things out the
safer things are gonna be but I also
think that we put in a lot of work this
year we've only got you know what we
played 62 games or something like that
we've almost got it got it done so
crowning a champion if it's possible and
if it's safe I think we should still
strive for that
sure have you heard a plan that you
think would work well I'm only hearing
you know the same plans you guys are
hearing and I think that getting it done
and getting the competition on I think
for everybody's general psyche I mean
fans know fans just getting something on
TV and some competition that the that
the world not not only this country but
globally can can tune in and watch I
think would be would be great for
everybody
what would we hear if there were no fans
and we're watching an NBA game yeah I
think you're gonna hear a lot well I
think I think a lot of us would have to
adjust our our normal in-game routine
whatever well wait how colorful is your
language during again well much more
colorful than my mother would hope I
hate to admit that but I've like to cut
back on it someday and maybe someday I
will
does it ever help when a coach yells at
a player oh for sure but can't you get
that I might the message I get to my
kids the lower my voice the more impact
I have and whenever a coach used to yell
at me I just tune him out after a while
yeah for sure
yeah I don't think you can do it very
constantly I think you know ever you
know you say ever yeah it does sometimes
I don't make a habit of yelling at the
players at all and rarely I think I
think you're probably looking at a
half-dozen times for a season maybe and
and maybe less than that for four brief
moments in a film room or something is a
player allowed to yell back for sure for
sure man were grown men here we're
having a discussion
did you ever yell like everybody's
participating sometimes did you ever
yell at koi I think so I did have some I
mean yeah maybe maybe well maybe one or
two times in a film session when we lot
when we went down old one to Orlando in
the opening round I don't think anybody
was spared that the next couple days
there
including and it was pretty it was
pretty a change of feeling and momentum
and thinking and attitude that we needed
quickly it's hard to envision you mad
like you seem chill well I think a lot
of us are chilled and very nice and when
the competition starts when the
competition starts you know you're
competing and it's it's tough out there
I think it's one of the things we see in
the the last dance stuff man one that
when it's the heat of the battle we're
seeing some guys that are anything to
win and physical and knocking people
around and who and and whatever it takes
you know but yeah I know you're a
Chicago
how big a Gordon fan were you I'm I was
I was really you know I was big I was a
big fan I was caught up in the era of
greatness and you know I was I was
probably more of a phil fan I was
already a young coach and I was really
more fascinated probably with with Phil
Jackson then then then Michael but I
mean obviously I mean listen I used to
get in my car and drive five hours from
Des Moines into Chicago by a
standing-room-only ticket and watch the
game and drive five hours back for the
same day to go to coach my coach my team
at Grandview University the next morning
you know but you're trying I know that
we it was acceptable back then admired
back then
imagine if LeBron played that way and
his personality was that way
would we would we allow LeBron to be the
same way Michael was in the nineties
well I don't know I think that's again a
fascinating thing to watch I think that
certainly is different with the social
media constant glare of that in this day
and age I think it I think it would
certainly take a different you know
thing but listen
LeBron's competing like he's competing
like crazy too now I've seen enough of
him up close to know that he's he's out
there to do whatever it takes to win -
but when you watch LeBron
would you ever allow LeBron in your mind
to be better than Michael Jordan what
can he do that you would go alright he's
gonna be top ten scoring and insist when
it's all
said and done you can't ask for much
more than that from an offensive player
yeah he's incredible dan I think I think
that the only thing I can I can say is
this is you've tried to try to come up
with game plans to stop him over and
over and haven't haven't really been
very successful he he's seen it all he
he knows how to adjust to everything he
he really really as a pass
you know minded player he really gets
other people the ball and he throws that
thing a hundred miles an hour right to
the shooting pocket you know he makes
the reads he doesn't get rattled very
often you know he's got a lot of things
that make him really really tough too
but who has a bigger impact on the game
10 or 15 years from now LeBron or Steph
Curry well I think they both have a huge
impact I think what Steph has done as
far as shooting from 30 feet or 35 feet
or whatever has changed all over the
world I think little kids all over the
world are bombing from you know the
three-point line but that they say
forget about the 3-point line let's
let's back up another 10 feet and shoot
too because because this guy does it and
they emulate him and in the freedom that
that curve you know Steve Kerr's giving
him and he's created and the skill and
all that stuff has certainly changed the
game a lot I think but we can't be like
Mike Nick we can't be like LeBron but
all of us think we can be like Steph
Curry that's why I think his impact will
be it'll be even larger than Michaels
from the standpoint of every kid thinks
he can play in the NBA we knew we
couldn't do it Mike did we can't be six
nine to 70 like LeBron Steph Curry we
can be 6-3 190 it's a great point I
agree with you work on your handles like
crazy figure out how to shoot lower
release points so you can shoot it from
40 feet and and well he practices a
little bit too you know if I said if we
were gonna have a game of horse NBA
coaches yes
give me two other guys you don't want to
go against two I want to go again no
give me the two bad
[Laughter]
give me the best game if we played horse
with NBA coaches po-boy that's well let
me just off the top of my head I
obviously think who are the really
really good players Steve Kerr Steve
Kerr Doc Rivers was an incredible player
can Popovich shoot I assume at some
point in his life he's a good player too
okay that's a good question I have to
think about so you Doc Rivers and Steve
Kerr huh you Doc Rivers Steve Kerr why
are you putting me in there I'm like
[Laughter]
great great NBA careers multiple
multiple playoff wins championship wins
yeah but you can shoot right you were
one of the great shooters in Northern
Iowa history shoot a little bit for a
mid-level College are you better that
are you better shooter than anybody on
the Raptors of course
who are you better than most of that
didn't take long to bring that out no
shooter shooters are gonna think they
can shoot I love that you would take
Steve Kerr on I would but he beat me he
would look they probably would you know
yeah he didn't
how about Rick Carlisle Rick Carlisle is
another he's some footage of Rick there
in the in the last dance that was pretty
cool yeah well he was trying to play
defense but if you made the last dance
that means you played and you were
guarding Mike I would take that get
embarrassed say you guarded him the NIC
nice Foundation and the limited edition
t-shirt
do you have the t-shirt on I have a
boxing one t-shirt on right now that's
coming to the foundation shortly oh good
that brings back bad memories coach why
my senior year state basketball
tournament
I played a boxing the one on me oh boy
and I got shut down yes
I hate boxing one sorry I think it's
cheap
really yeah guard me sorry about that
yeah boxing won't be the shirt say be a
team player stay strong stay safe and
you've got your sunglasses on they're
holding the Larry O'Brien trophy the
foundation supports children young
adults through exposure to music sports
and literacy when'd you come up with
this well you hi Ron eclis we've been
we've been obviously planning the
foundation for a while we actually had
our kickoff a night of music and support
of the foundation on March 11th we lit
we literally were wrapping it up when no
news as Rudy Gobert came out like we
were all there we I went straight to the
hospital to get tested right from right
from that event so we did we just kicked
it off and we're just trying to again
we're trying to you know the the kovin
19 has changed things a little bit so
we're trying to figure out a way to
support some kids through this and raise
some money and that kind of stuff what's
the official website is it just Nick
nurse foundation or yeah yeah foundation
org yeah awesome good to talk to you I'm
gonna see if I can set up this horse
game with you and some of these other
coaches here okay I'll be there I like
it
thank you coach great to talk to you
again that's Nick nursing my Toronto
Raptors